vampire teeth boom vampire teeth good
spiderwebs done fake blood capsules
oh they didn't have any really
that's gross i love it we are throwing a
halloween party at our house it's gonna
be the greatest thing ever
someone will die of fun and of murder
there's gonna be beer
pumpkins bloody goblins fake ones it's
gonna be awesome we have decorations
dead people that we just murdered not
murdered but pictures of dead people
from tv or movies mutilated bodies
but fake ones candy dancing tequila all
kinds of food and snacks blood orphans
no blood orphans
i i don't know what that is
donna blue shirt
badge nightstick you
are a policewoman yep you're a regular
sherlock holmes
i solved that mystery before you did
okay this is fun
andy you are ufc legend chuck liddell
that's right
girl from the ring to me sherlock holmes
is
literally the greatest character in the
western canon
smart intuitive handsome replaces pasty
british frailty with superhuman physical
fitness and you get
sherlock traeger hey ron
good to see ya what's your pirate last
year
yes this is my halloween costume andrew
are you aware that your bathroom faucet
is leaking
are you kidding me i just stuffed a sock
in it yesterday
what else do they want me to do there's
an exposed wire above the bathtub as
well
oh yeah shockwire i call it that because
if you take a shower
and you touch the wire you die
yes that is accurate hey there
is there a project you're working on i
know more than you
all right hey listen if you're mad about
something
you should just i'm not i'm not mad
really listen i feel like you are mad so
maybe you should just talk to us
about it my name
i'm mad all right that was great thank
you
thanks for that your fingers are salty
i'm gonna finish my work
oran no no stay out
hey ben hey guy you weren't coming to
the party well i'm just
having a butterfinger oh really is that
okay
no if you're not part of the party you
can't have the candy
back up all right back up okay i have
one sister
we steal each other's stuff hack each
other's twitter accounts
set each other's clothes on fire there
are no rules
i need to get more chips all right
let's go
come on walk no this is a pacifist
protest
had enough you need to let go of me come
on yeah
get it that's good oh here we go
he's got us back come on
nice yeah oh my god andy i am so sorry
oh psych blood capsules
what yeah i wanted to shock you into
expressing your anger
and that way my nose is broken oh no
vice principal emergency what is it i
have to leave
some idiot kids were caught pooping on
the soccer field
oh too bad guess trick-or-treating's
over no
no we can walk him around it's no
problem we just got started
oh that's so sweet of you now ladies
princess mommy has to go and take care
of some bad guys so you be nice to ron
and andy okay
okay let's go to the next house i need
to go to the bathroom
i i have no idea what to do about that
7 34 p.m man dressed as a nerd
female dressed as crazy witch neither of
us is in costume
case closed candy please run zoey broke
my tiara
we both have the same tiara now she has
one and i
don't okay i didn't meet you right okay
well let's let's just even things out
there now neither of you has a tiara
problem solved
hey i know it would cheer you up let's
go wait outside the bathroom for tom
and scare him that would cheer me up
okay ready
jerry god gross
oh jerry guys
oh god oh i think he might be having a
heart attack what
are you serious oh so much stuff is
happening right now call 9-1-1
okay just breathe okay you're going to
be fine no
jeez did a dinosaur just fart jerry get
a grip sorry guys
apology not accepted stop talking [ __ ]
i wish i could stop smelling dude
seriously jerry did you eat farts for
lunch tom jerry's having a heart attack
oh no i didn't know that jerry you okay
greg pachitis
you're the parks lady right yeah that's
right i'm the parks lady
leslie knope and i'm here to tell you
that this year
it ends ugh this kid makes me crazy we
got a history
greg and i he absolutely terrorizes the
park system
every halloween someone defaces the
statue of mayor percy in ramsett park
and i know it's greg pochettis but i've
never been able to prove it
he's like an invisible adolescent james
bond supervillain criminal
mastermind
or maybe someone else is doing it but i
really feel like it's this kid
got the entire parks department watching
you my boyfriend's a cop
so don't even try it i don't know what
you're talking about oh i think you do
it ends today pocatus it ends
two day
thanks for stopping by leslie you look
great thank you
ends today
[Music]
hey guys hey remember
my boyfriend derek and his boyfriend ben
yeah hi it's totally okay that you
didn't wear a costume
i did i'm a straight person hey
sorry i'm late see
sorry it's a little bit lame right now
but we'll get it going
i passed up a gay halloween party to be
here do you know how much fun
gay halloween parties are last year i
saw three jonas brothers make out with
three robert pattisons
it was amazing and do you have any
mounds because all i can find are almond
joys
and almonds give me the squirts
hey i'm here statue's fine
crappy halloweeners that's hilarious
where's the kid
in the conference room trying to hide
his obvious guilt
leslie i don't know what to tell you i
don't i don't think he did it yeah he
did
and we need a confession okay
andy and i are going to take a walk and
it's going to be just you
pocatus and these pliers look i'm not
gonna torture this kid nobody said
torture
why don't you let me take a run at him
boss in order to think
like one of these guys you have to think
like them
yeah he's never seen you before so imply
that you're someone very important
and that you can make his life hell
greg pochitas would you like some
boiling hot coffee your face
my name is bert macklin yeah i'm with
the
fbi
[Music]
huh looks like andy's wearing him down
i'm gonna go finish him off
that is the dumbest thing i've ever
heard don't you just shut up for a
second
what's going on he's he's a jerk he's
being such a
jerk it's an awful thing to say to his
human being are you crying no i'm not
crying okay
i'm allergic to jerks okay andy ouch
fine i don't
care it's stupid i'm calling your shift
commander
monday morning i am calling your boss i
don't know who to call about you
the president of the united states of
america fine
babe you look more beautiful right now
than i have ever seen you
wow just your luck that you're going
into labor on halloween
can i get a warm towel to get that
makeup off no i want it on
that's the whole point i put the makeup
on after i went into labor
whatever blows your skirt up okay you
ready to push
wait no babe my birth mix
[Music]
here comes a are you ready okay i'm
ready let's do this
you